>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Ryan Moore: Welcome, my name
is Ryan Moore, I'm a specialist
in the Geography and Map Division.
And today's event is sponsored by
the Philip Lee Phillips Map Society
of the Library of Congress.
The Map Society was
established in 1995 to enhance
and promote the collections of
the Geography and Map Division.
Thank you.
The society is free to join, but
donations are greatly appreciated.
Donations are used to help purchase
rare maps, sponsor publications
and lectures like today's event.
In May we're going to have an event
on the 13th here at the Library
of Congress, 300 Years of Map in
Cuba by Professor Perez Hernandez
who lived in Cuba and he has
lectured at places such as Harvard
on the topic of Cuban history
and Cuban architecture.
It should be a very
interesting event.
Presently, the society has
published its latest journal known
as the Occasional Papers, they're
free to pick up in the back.
It looks like this if you can see
through all the bright lights.
It's by Louis De Vorsey, it's
on the history of a Gulfstream
and the thesis of this work is
that Benjamin Franklin
was credited too hastily
with discovering the Gulfstream.
And there was another scientist
who actually preceded him
in the discovery of that.
Very interesting work, please
pick one up it's in the back.
So before we begin with talking
about crowd source mapping Curtis
and I had a little
conversation and we wanted
to establish some historical and
cultural context for this event.
Why is it relevant to
crowd source North Korea.
Why should that happen, what is
important about that practice?
So what I want to do is highlight
a few things concerning the history
and culture of the Korean
Peninsula in North Korea.
So premodern Korea had
isolationist policies often referred
to as the hermit kingdom and that
phrase actually has been attached
to North Korea today.
The Peninsula itself was a singular
entity until the end of World War 2.
The Japanese through establishing
treaties, a protectorate
and then formally annexing
Korea from 1910
to 1945 were present
on the peninsula.
At the end of World War
2 they were forced out.
We see the beginnings
of the Cold War.
The Soviet Union occupied the
northern half of the country,
American forces were
stationed in the South.
Both sides and this was along,
roughly along the 30th parallel
where the country is divided today.
Both sides talked about
reunification, they couldn't agree
on a system of government.
In 1949, the US and the
USSR withdraw their forces,
North Korea is arming heavily
at this time receiving
state-of-the-art technology
from the Soviet Union.
South Korea is not
receiving much in the way
of weapons from the United States.
In 1950 in June, North Korea
launches a blitzkrieg attack
into the south and nearly
overruns the country.
The last line of defense is in
[inaudible] the United Nations led
by the United States and
Great Britain come to the aid
of South Korea and turn
the situation around.
They actually roll back the North
Koreans across the 38th parallel
and as they close on the Alou
River, the Chinese border,
the People's Republic
of China enters the war.
And we have then a situation of
stalemates along the 38th parallel.
Finally, a cease-fire
is signed, however,
there is no formal
peace treaty in place.
The countries are technically
still at war.
And we see here a map by the
Central Intelligence Agency
of the DMZ created in 1969.
This is part of the
geography and map collection.
Koreans call this Hu Jun sun, the
cease-fire line and it stretches
across the entire peninsula
150 miles.
And everywhere along this line
on both sides are military
installations, artillery, tanks.
They call it the demilitarized zone,
probably the biggest misnomer
you can apply to the situation.
It is one of the most
militarized places on earth.
And if you see the waters to the
left those areas are in dispute
between the two countries and
there has been live shooting,
people have died in contesting
where the northern limit is
of those waters, where
the southern limit is
of those waters, has
a right to be there.
I would like to touch a little bit
about North Korean
geography and place names.
The North Koreans in sort of
every day common language refer
to themselves as Choson
referring to the Choson dynasty.
They see South Korea as an extension
of their country they call it
Nam Choson, Nam meaning south.
Mind you, South Korea also
has their own place names.
The common name of Korea Hangul.
You're referring to North
Korea as an extension
of their country Phuket
Kong, Phuket meaning north.
So you would often hear about in
Korean news Nam Phuket relations,
so north and south.
The capital city of
North Korea, Pyongyang.
North Korea shares
borders with China,
Russia and also South
Korea along the DMZ.
It's a larger country than
its neighbor in the south,
neighbor is maybe not
the right word,
but they're brothers,
it's a house divided.
The climate of North Korea is hot,
humid summers, very cold winters.
Most of the land is very mountainous
and I'm going to illustrate
that with some maps
from the division.
Numerous deep, narrow valleys,
most of the people live
in valleys on the coastal plains.
And despite this massive area
of real estate only some 18%
of that land is arable and
you'll see why with this map.
This map was drawn in 1944
by a cartographer named
Richard Eades Harrison.
He worked for Fortune
Magazine, Time Life Magazine.
He came into popularity
because he presented cartography
from a different perspective.
He said why do we always
show the map top-down,
show the map that highlights
the information
that you want the viewer to see.
So in this map if you look
at the Korean peninsula you can see
how absolutely mountainous it is,
in particular North Korea.
And then you see the coastal
plains where Pyongyang sits.
And that's where the farming, the
breadbasket of North Korea lies.
Important to understanding
some of psychology and thinking
of North Korea, as
well as appreciating
that of South Korea was
the Japanese occupation.
They call it the Iljay
Shide [assumed spelling],
the time of the Japanese Empire.
Here we have a map of Pyongyang
made by the Japanese in 1921.
And as you can see, the name
Pyongyang does not appear
on the map.
This is the idea of
cultural erasure,
colonialism where the Japanese
have appropriated the place
and the name of the place.
And in the pictures that ring this
map, it's a tourist map by the way,
in the bottom corner you see a
Mitsubishi factory the Japanese are
highlighting that we've
modernized the city,
we are bringing industry
to this peninsula.
And as you look through the
pictures you see a Buddhist temple,
an old Korean ship.
So they're saying well this is the
old way we're the new way and we're
in harmony with all these
lovely flowers ringing,
winding through the photographs.
And there is resentment in
North Korea and South Korea
to this day about this time period.
This is a map made by the
North Koreans themselves
and I chose it precisely because
it has the sort of the same the map
of the city ringed by illustrations.
This was created for the 13th
international youth festival held
in 1989.
This map was actually produced a
year before that in preparation.
The North Korean government spared
no expense spending a fourth
of their budget, millions
of dollars,
to put on a big international show.
And now we see in the top left
corner there they're highlighting
their strength as a nation, their
Juche Tower, something I'll talk
about a little bit later.
And in the lower right-hand corner
their metro system, which they tout
as one of the best in the world
and anyone who visits Pyongyang
and I have not they take
them to these metro centers
that are very ornate stations
with murals on the walls
and they're very ornately decorated.
In this map as well like the
other is available to view
and be researched here at
the Library of Congress.
The North Korean government is a
hereditary dictatorship supported
by a single party.
The Kim family, the Kim
Dynasty has absolute power.
These titles here in quotes
these are things required
of the North Korean people to say
when they reference
one of these leaders.
It is an extreme insult and
probably trouble with the government
to address one of these
leaders without the title.
The eternal president, the
eternal general, the marshal.
Incidentally, Kim Il-sung
was a partisan fighter
against the Japanese known for
extreme brutality in his tactics
against the Japanese
and the Japanese themselves were
a very fierce opponent in war.
And he idolized Joseph Stalin
in many ways and thought
to model North Korea
off the Soviet Union,
but with his own personal spin.
And that's what we're
talking about here Juche,
this concept of self-reliance.
This ideology is very hard
to explain what I'm telling you
here is a very distilled simplified
version, but it's a
mixture of communism,
nationalism and Confucianism.
The leadership holds a place that's
nearly religious in the country.
And they are governing
24.7 million people,
in the South 48.9 million people.
They have a greater area in
the north, smaller population.
They tout the fact that they provide
healthcare, education, housing,
food, etcetera for their
population with a caveat.
The quality of life depends
on a person's loyalty ranking.
North Korea begins a file on anyone
over the age of 17 you're classified
as loyal to the regime,
wavering to the regime
or on the outs with the regime.
And if you're on the outs with the
regime almost three generations it
takes to be rehabilitated to
be brought back into the fold.
So if someone commits an
offense they, their children
and their children's
children are ostracized.
And this is a political
cast system known
as sung-boon meaning constituents.
And as we know, for many defectors
North Korea there's limited civil
liberties, state-controlled
press and internet.
There is restrictions on
travel to and from North Korea.
Our guests, Mr. Melvin, he
can't visit North Korean
as you can imagine he's revealing
too much information about them.
A great tragedy is happening in
North Korea is chronic shortages
of food, energy and medicine.
And this coincides with
the end of the Soviet Union
who are bankrolling the
North Koreans in many ways
like they were bankrolling the
Cubans and the East Germans
and all these other countries.
This cash flow has stopped.
And the North Korean priorities,
which I'll get to in a minute,
are military not treating
their people.
And so they're relying on foreign
aid and has gone back and forth
where the United Nations, the United
States, South Korea is sending food
and medicine to them and
they're turning around
and they're still arming themselves.
And that has to do with this
second ideology of North Korea.
Sun-goon army first, sun from the
Chinese character primary first,
goon as Yuk goon army, military.
It's like a modern day Sparta.
They have the world's
fourth largest military
and while they have dated technology
in the right hands
it's very lethal stuff.
And most of their equipment would
have been considered modern during
the Vietnam era, that's the highest
level of technology they have
in terms of fighters and
tanks dating back to the 70's.
Why does it stop there because the
Russians are no longer sending them
the latest stuff?
And this we'll get to our last
point here before we bring
up Mr. Melvin about nuclear weapons.
They're spending an
outrageously high amount
of money on defense 8.2 billion.
They have an active military
of 1.1 million people.
Ten years of mandatory
service in the military,
it's an incredibly long period
of time to have the young men
of your nation to committed
to military service instead
of developing their minds
and developing the
economy of the nation.
They are preoccupied with training
for war and they use incidentally
for pet projects of
the regime to build,
to act as construction workers,
to help in harvest time.
And their special forces, which is
numbers around some 200,000 soldiers
and I don't want to say men
because women are under arms
in North Korea too, it's
15 years of service.
That's an incredibly long
period of time as well.
This contrasts with South Korea
some 655,000 soldiers and depending
on the branch of service
22 to 24 months.
There's two different
mentalities towards defense
and defense preparation
as you can see.
Total militarized population
of North Korea is an
astounding 7.6 million people.
You remember we said there's
24 some million people living
in North Korea.
Close to a third of their
people are under arms.
The capital of South Korea Seoul
is in a precarious position,
it's not far some 30 some miles
from the DMZ and it is in range
of North Korean artillery.
It's projected that there's
some 13,000 artillery pieces
in that sector of the DMZ that are
ready to shoot should a war begin.
And let me tell you Seoul is
a beautiful massive sprawling
metropolis and if you have a chance
to go there I encourage
you to do so.
But like any big city,
especially Seoul is divided
by a river, the Han River.
Traffic is a nightmare and should
an emergency happen it would be
absolute pandemonium and panic
should the North Koreans start
shooting on Seoul.
Korea, North Korea also has
chemical and nuclear weapons
and they are developing
a long-range missile
if you've been watching the news.
That they are keen on being able
to shoot the West Coast
of the United States.
They are pushing an envelope
and it's a game of chess
and Russian roulette
at the same time.
The resolution of that I
don't know I can't predict,
but with the way things are going
it can't continue this way I'm
sure this.
And this is my last point
before we bring up our guest.
Is that we also have to talk about
people when we talk about politics
and maps because that's
what this is all about
and how this stuff impacts
the lives of everyday people.
There's this concept on the
Korean peninsula of isan gajog,
the separated families who
were divided by the Korean War.
The Korean War as I briefly
mentioned earlier, had a lot of push
and pull back across the peninsula.
Brothers and sisters, husband
and wife, families were separated
because of this and they never
saw one another again often.
We were talking about from the
war civilian deaths some 5 million
people killed, wounded
or missing and more
than half of them are civilians.
And it left some 10 million people
separated from their families,
that's a huge amount of their
population that is divided
by this experience and it
cuts very deep in their soul.
They talk about the wounding
or the scarring of the soul,
sung cho [assumed spelling] and the
resentment that follows that, Han,
different Han from Han
Guk, Han Guk means Koreas.
Han here means anger,
hate, resentment.
The South Korean government
stepped up in the 80's to try
to reunite people both
in South Korea,
those living abroad
and with North Korea.
And the sad fact is that with the
attempt to reunite families North
and South they often are only given
three days with people who are
at the very end of their life.
Go see your sister in North
Korea it's okay for three days
and haven't seen each
other in so long.
And there was a very famous
song in Korea that symbolizes
or typifies the feelings that
people have for not seeing
in one another since
childhood perhaps.
Patty Kim is a very
famous Korean singer
and she has this lyric
here [foreign language],
don't you know this person, you
haven't seen them your whole life
and you're looking at somebody.
It's very tragic and it's why
this crowdsourcing work is very
important, we want to open
the doors and know more.
And hopefully that can
affect positive policy.
And so I say here, you know,
North Korea [foreign language],
this country I don't
know, none of us know,
we're trying to understand better,
we're trying to see what is inside
to effect and change
things for the better.
And with that being said,
I would like to bring
up our guest Mr. Melvin.
He is a researcher at
the US Korean Institute,
excuse me John Hopkins University.
He is a contributor to the
website 38 North and editor
of the blog North Korean
Economy Watch.
He's been studying and writing
about North Korea since 2006
and he actually visited there as
I mentioned and has been banned
for the next point being a creator
of the North Korea Uncovered
in DPRK Digital Atlas, which
he'll be addressing today.
He received his master's degree
in economics from George Mason
and a bachelor's degree in economics
from the University of Georgia.
Please welcome Mr. Melvin.
[ Applause ]
>> Curtis Melvin: Good afternoon
everyone, thanks for coming out.
My name's Curtis Melvin.
As was mentioned, I'm a researcher
at the US Korean Institute
at Johns Hopkins.
This talk is a little different
than the one I normally do.
Normally, I'm asked to talk about
what satellite imagery shows us
about North Korea's
changing economic landscape.
But today I'm focusing more
on actual mapping issues.
So it was fun to put this project
together and share some of the kind
of nerdy mapping issues
that I deal with at home
that nobody really
gets to address much.
I started this project
after visiting North
Korea in 2004 and 2005.
This is me, a younger,
skinnier single version of me
in Kim Il-sung Square in Pyongyang.
The country has changed
tremendously since then.
But anyway when I visited at this
time I didn't know any Korean
and a lot of map information
on the country was very
difficult to come by.
So I would visit places and
not have any idea where I was.
And this was one of the first
things I tried to address
after getting out of the country.
The last nap we saw of Pyongyang
from 1988 for the World Festival
of Youth and Students I had
never seen that one before.
The first map I got of Pyongyang
was the one they gave me
when I visited, it
was produced in 1997.
This tourist map shows a lot of
the places that you might visit
or you could have visited at
the time in central Pyongyang.
But it's not very engaging,
you can't interact with this,
the information is limited in scope.
And it's not to scale and it's
missing a lot of key important areas
that as a visitor you
might like to know about.
For instance, this
area right here is
where the [inaudible]
party headquarters is
and it' snot even labeled
on there in any way.
And so it's very lacking in
telling you what you can learn
about the city.
This is the project I'm working
on it's kind of a mess [inaudible]
on purpose to show how much
more information we can collect
on North Korea.
This is using Google Earth,
which is satellite information
where I've literally by hand labeled
buildings and infrastructure.
So this exists on my computer
right now and I'll speak
about where it's going in the
future, but no detail is too small.
You know, we know where
the photo studios are,
we know where the grocery
stores are.
We have all of the buildings in
the worker's party complex labeled.
We even know about some
tunnels under them.
Kin Chong-in's residency is in
the complex shopping centers,
other government buildings, schools.
The blue line here is
the railway system.
We also have the tram and trolley
lines, so no detail is too small
and we can choose which
kind of data we want to look
at to spatially compare them
and learn about how they relate
to each other through geography.
And this is something
that's very difficult to do
with an actual paper map.
And as an aside, the previous map I
just showed you this one from 1997,
up until last fall when I went to
Seoul this was the most recent map
that I could ever find that the
North Koreans made of Pyongyang.
And last summer or last fall I went
to Seoul and a colleague had been
in Pyongyang in 2012
and got this map.
This is still the only one I've ever
seen and people who go in and out
of North Korea check for this
stuff to obtain it for me.
And so this one hasn't even
been widely circulated,
but it's a vast improvement
over the old 1997 map.
It's kind of hard to tell here, but
the different parts of the city,
the different districts, the gu yok,
in South Korea they're called gu.
But they've actually
delineated them in this map,
so you can see the different
districts in different colors.
And the [inaudible], the blocks,
the subunits of the district
are more specifically identified
and also some of the new
construction projects
that have taken place between
the 1997 map and 2012 map appear.
But also again, very limited
and the purpose is not really tell
you much about the city right.
You can't go to Pyongyang and wander
around to your favorite
new restaurant.
You're going to go on a preapproved
itinerary and you're going to eat
at the restaurants you're your
travel company has been approved
to take you to.
Another interesting aside from
that map is on the flipside,
on the back of it, it's the
only North Korean map I've seen
that shows the new
borders of Pyongyang.
Sometime before 2012 Pyongyang was
shrunk and this area of [inaudible]
in the county of [inaudible],
which were previously part
of Pyongyang were removed
and made part
of the neighboring
[inaudible] province.
And I was able to verify
this using data published
for the last supreme
people's assembly election,
but this is the first map I
had seen that actually showed
that it was produced in North Korea.
So I've been working on two kinds of
mapping projects with North Korea,
an administrative mapping and
an infrastructure mapping.
One thing that was frustrating
for me as if you look
at I learned Korean from
watching North Korean television
and in North Korean sources,
that's how I came into Korean,
I never really learned much
about South Korea ever.
But when South Koreans publish North
Korean mapping data they use South
Korean spellings, which in
some cases are different.
So for instance in North Korea
they have the Pyongyang province,
which they spell with, you know,
they spell it differently
than South Koreans.
And in Rason City, a
special economic zone
in the Northeast the North
Koreans spell that differently
in Korean and in English.
But if you look at
Google for instance,
they use only the South
Korean spelling.
Also, if you look at
Gazetteer data it hurts --
the Gazetteer data hurts my eyes.
It has not much in common with
North Korean sources at all and so
for instance if I was
interviewing a North Korean defector
about where they were from
and I showed this person the
Gazetteer data they wouldn't
recognize the names,
particularly the small villages.
Those have all changed I think
since that data was compiled.
And so everything that I've done on
the administrative side is entirely
from North Korean sources.
Several published atlases
that came out of North Korea,
including Atlas software and an
encyclopedia that someone got
in Pyongyang and gave to me.
And those have maps purely published
in North Korea and only in Korean.
I also use the North Korean
standard for romanizing the names,
so that if you wanted to
search the North Korean media
for those names you would find it.
And if you search for North
Korean places using South Korean
Romanization you won't find anything
because generally they
spell things --
they use a different standard
for translating in English.
The second project has been
infrastructure mapping.
This has been a labor of
love, but it has been a labor
of a very loving wife who
tolerates me doing this.
But no detail is too small,
we're interested in every aspect
of the geography that
can be identified on maps
and satellite imagery and
I work on this every day.
Anyway, there's the list of
things, just a sampling of things.
But literally if I made a
column of different kinds
of places we've identified,
I mean it would probably go
from the ceiling to
the floor in this room.
And this is a simple visualization
of the administrative mapping that's
on Google Earth, it's also
been published in other places,
but just to give you a sampling.
So this is [inaudible] city here
in yellow and this is [inaudible]
in blue to the north,
this is the produced area
of Pyongyang in green it's updated.
And then Pyongyang is [inaudible]
down to the different [inaudible].
And in here are the borders
of the [inaudible] and some
of the other villages
further out here.
And again, from all North
Korean sources at least four
of them, sometimes five or six.
And then to give you
a sampling of the kind
of infrastructure we're doing I've
been working on the electricity grid
for years, so you can that's
what these green lines are.
We can literally trace like which
facilities get their electricity
from which power plants
or don't in many cases.
But this is just an example where
I trace the power line from one
of the power plants to Kangdong
leadership, it was Kangdong
at the time's leadership
compound in Kangdong.
But that's the kind of fine
little details you can get
when you overlay different
data types together.
Also watching the railway
network has been fun.
North Korea's railway network until
recently was the primary means
of conveyance for getting
around the country.
The rail system was supplemental.
So watching changes to the railway
network is always interesting.
They haven't made any huge
changes recently except
to abandon several projects
that probably weren't
economically viable,
but they've also done
some fun things
like building special railway lines
for Kim Jong-Il in his last days
and linking up new mines mostly
for exporting raw materials.
This is the road network, again
I've drawn all this out by hand
on the satellite imagery
and it takes a long time.
I have the roads split up based
on whether they're level one, two,
three, four, five or six roads and
main road construction projects.
But we keep track of
all these changes
as new satellite imagery comes out.
The future of the project here --
so everything I've shown
you is basically a KMZ file
on the computer.
What we've done is the
administrative data we've published
it as the 38 North Digital Atlas
that's on our webpage, 38north.org.
And then the infrastructure
mapping we're trying to move
to a web-based system so that
researchers can use it more easily.
And it's such an enormous
and complex file,
it's taking a long
time to get this done.
But the end goal is to
build a web-based platform
where everybody can access this
data and to have a team of people
who are constantly monitoring
our various sources for updates
of that information and so
that it can always be updated
and made available to the public.
Why is this important, well
by combining satellite imagery
with the largest non-classified
database we can more easily monitor
changes across the country
and get a better sense
of what's happening there.
And to communicate these findings
to various North Korea stakeholders.
So information sources, this is a
lot of research and verification.
I lean very heavily on North
Korea's efficient, they're helpful
and they each have
their own drawbacks.
So official publications,
North Korean television KCTV,
Naenara is a North Korean web
portal it's updated every day.
Uriminzokkiri is a North Korean
organization that targets contents
to overseas Koreans and Choson Sinbo
is run by Koreans who are loyal
to North Korean who live in Japan.
Any books and software that the
North Koreans publish the Library
of Congress has a tremendous
collection of these items
as does the Seoul National
Library in South Korea.
Although the Library of Congress
ones are easier to access.
The drawbacks for these official
publications, you get a wealth
of information, you probably
get the most timely information
if a new factory has been built
or something has changed names
you're most likely only going
to find out about it through
official publications.
But these only cover places that
the North Korean government wants
to highlight.
So if you're interested
in, you know,
developments at a military site or
a prison camp they're never going
to be updated on the North
Korean official publications,
you can only get information
about that from satellite imagery
or from interviewing defectors.
Declassified documents are
really helpful, you know,
the intelligence community has
been researching a lot of places
in North Korea for decades.
You can get declassified documents
on North Korea up till the 1980's,
I think I haven't seen
anything from the 90's yet.
And these are really helpful,
they generally have maps
and some old satellite
images in them.
They have a lot of coordinates
which still work if you want
to copy those coordinates
into Google Earth.
The problem with declassified
documents is
in this case you're
getting they're very old,
so the 1980's is a long
time ago in North Korea.
Even North Korea has changed
significantly since then.
There are also sort
of targets things
that we might be interested
in blowing up one day.
So if you're interested
in a new paper factory
or fishing station it's
probably not going to be in them.
The other thing that's frustrating
is the declassified documents refer
to the places -- generally refer
to the places they've identified
by what the intelligence community
calls them or what they used
to be called not what the North
Koreans actually call them.
And so there are a
number of times I found
out where I would identify a
factory from a North Korean source
and describe a name to it and then I
would see a name that was unfamiliar
in a declassified document and
I would punch in the coordinates
and find out that they were
the same thing it's just
that the intelligence community
had a different name for this place
than the North Koreans did.
And so as far as I know I'm the
only one who is in the business
of putting this data together.
Defector interviews is
another source of information.
I interviewed a North
Korean defector yesterday.
Defector interviews can be really
rewarding and really frustrating.
There's a little over
27,000 North Koreans
who have entered South Korea now.
The numbers have been going down
since Kim Jong-Il came to office
and the South Korean government
hasn't published the 2015 numbers
as far as I'm aware.
But most North Korean defectors come
from the northern provinces
along the Chinese border
from small villages.
Sometimes they're from the
provincial capital cities,
but in general a lot of --
there's not many, you know,
there's just several, most North
Korean defectors really don't know
much more than what's going on
in their personal lives even
if they're from a large city.
They have a hard time
looking at satellite imagery
and rectifying satellites or a map
with the maps that
are in their heads.
And a lot of times they
just don't know much more
than where they lived, where they
went to school, where they worked
or where they went shopping.
And then you also have
additional problems
where I've had defectors
not tell the truth.
They have fabricated and
one woman I'm thinking
of in particular fabricated
an entire story of her life
in Pyongyang and where she
worked and where she lived.
And you know she picked a very --
a well-known factory as her place
of employment and as I
asked her specific details
about the neighborhood she lived in,
about which I already had some data,
she confessed and said if
you want to know this kind
of information I have to tell
you it from a different town
because I don't know it here.
And so anyway and that's
happened several times.
So you have to be really careful
when interviewing defectors
because sometimes they'll
also pass off information
of what they think something is
instead of what they know it is.
And so I have a separate
file for defector information
that I'm not sure about
that doesn't make it
into the actual infrastructure
mapping.
But one thing that the
defectors have been
and this is the case yesterday the
lady didn't know much about the city
that I didn't already
have, but what she did know
that was really helpful
was she was able to help
on the administrative side.
So we have maps of Pyongyang,
but some of the smaller cities
in North Korea getting
the names of the dong,
the local blocks is really hard
to come by in detailed maps
and she was able to say like
this neighborhood is called this
and this neighborhood
is called this.
And as far as I'm aware
that's not published anywhere,
I mean North Koreans don't even see
that kind of data growing up there.
It might exist somewhere
in South Korea,
but I've never come across it.
DPRK visitors and stakeholders,
so aid workers, business ventures,
tourists, diplomats, surprisingly
tourists have been really helpful.
You know, some are pretty
daring and they take pictures
of stuff I don't even know what
it is and I can go through it
and match it up with
satellite imagery and find
out it's a meat shop or some
new restaurant that's gone up.
The aid workers, the
business people and people
from the diplomatic community those
contacts take a little harder --
a little more work to develop
because obviously people are shy
about letting information out or
jeopardizing their work there.
I also wanted to point out that
I'm not sure what the definition
of crowdsourcing is, but if it's
getting tips from strangers,
that's not what I've done.
Nearly every piece of data that I've
put in this project has a citation
and you can visually see where I
got the data from and verify it.
I even have links to North Korean
television in it, so you can see
for yourself that the data
that I published matches
the North Korean source.
This was an example of
finding something fun.
This is sort of what we
go through all the time.
But this is a number of
years ago Kim Jong-Il
when he was still alive
visited KPA unit number 586,
which is also the Reconnaissance
Bureau, which is responsible
for operations in South Korea.
And using the official footage
from his visit there we found
the location in Pyongyang.
And I'm not saying this is the
only Reconnaissance Bureau compound
in Pyongyang, it's obviously
one of them and, you know,
we matched the buildings and
the monuments with what we saw
in the satellite imagery.
And I actually didn't find this
one of my colleagues found this,
but we can still cite the
source for it because it was
in North Korean publications.
And this one was fun, it was a
secret Burmese military delegation
visited North Korea in 2009.
It wasn't reported in
the official media.
They went there to go buy
some military equipment.
Someone from that delegation
released their photos
and so I was able to look at
these photos and find just
about everywhere that
they went in North Korea.
And this was someplace where
they went to look at some --
I think it was some
antiaircraft equipment
or something software demonstration.
And so I saw a picture of this
building and I was looking all
over Pyongyang for it and then I
found this picture and it looked
like it matched the
ground-level photo.
And I was able to task someone in
Pyongyang to drive by this and see
if that was the building and
so I was able to verify it
with someone on the ground.
And this was defector
testimony where I used
for a publication a number of
years ago for the Committee
for Human Rights in North
Korea on Japanese defectees.
Anh-Young Jin [assumed
spelling] was a defector.
They did this hand-drawn map
of where the [inaudible] go,
the Red Army hijackers were living
in the outskirts of Pyongyang.
And when I was given the map they
didn't include the key to it,
so this [inaudible] upside
down because they gave me the
map with south at the top.
And so I was looking around for
that I couldn't find it anywhere
and when I turned it upside down
and then I found the thing it's very
important to put the key in there.
But anyway, that was much
harder than it should have been.
And in here this is the
Mirae Scientist's Street
in Pyongyang it was just completed.
It's sort of maybe the fifth large
residential contract to take place
in Pyongyang since 2012 or
maybe 2010 and it's on the.
Anyway, I've already got photos
of all of these buildings
from the ground, so I'm just waiting
to get a new satellite picture
and then I can label where
all the shops and restaurants
and buildings are along there.
And that's using person
sources and North Korean sources
because North Koreans have
shown many of these places
in their official outlets as well.
[Inaudible] is that blue
shop in the middle there.
On the administrative side it's also
kind of tricky to combine the data
and figure out what the
reality is, what the truth is.
Every single map that
I have of Kaesong
that the North Koreans have
published looks like this.
So Kaesong City, Kaesong is like
New York it's a city, it's comprised
of a big area called Kaesong
and a small area called Kaesong.
So Kaesong City also
includes Kaesong County,
it did include [inaudible] County,
Kaesong City and Jhinga County.
And every single map I have shows
this configuration for this area.
And I stumbled on a story in
the KCNA, which is the outlet
that North Korea uses to convey
official information to outsiders.
And KCNA said that in 2002
[inaudible], this is in setting
up the Kaesong industrial zone,
which was just closed
a few days ago.
That [inaudible] County had been
dissolved and renamed into a re,
it had been downgraded
from a town an oop to a re.
And the other villages
around it had been moved
into Kapong, Kaesong and Pyongyang.
And so because the KCNA article
listed all of the re and all
of those re matched the ones
I had on the maps I was able
to I think accurately plot, although
I haven't actually seen this map
anywhere from a North Korean source
the new boundaries of Kaesong.
It's up here this Pyongyang re is
what used to be [inaudible] Town.
And now Kaesong comes all the
way down to the new [inaudible].
Kapong comes all the way
down to the Han River
and these areas here they
used to be part of [inaudible]
and are now part of Kapong.
The Jangphung border came
down and so I just looked
for after moving the
villages in North Korea a lot
of the county borders are high
landmarks, so mountain ridges
and rivers and also railway
tracks and some other things.
But anyway, I just
used the high landmark
between where the villages
were supposed to be moved
around to figure out where the new
borders are between these areas.
But I still haven't
seen a North Korean nap
that has this configuration.
Another case that was frustrating is
in Phyonggang province North
Korea has a Phyonggang province,
I didn't realize until recently
that South Korea also has
a Phyonggang province,
but it was split in two.
And North Korea has changed a lot of
the borders in Phyonggang Province
because of a large dam projects.
But anyway, this is
Phyonggang County,
this right here is [inaudible].
A little [inaudible] is that all the
North Korean maps show the county
borders as if the DNZ was there.
And so they come into the actual
zone and they list villages
that maybe used to be there
and are still officially there.
But if you look at the satellite
imagery there's nothing there.
So on my map what I did was I
actually stopped at the DMZ.
On the North Korean side
you can see where that is
because there's a security
infrastructure there.
And then I just ignored the villages
that were on the North Korean maps
that were inside the DMZ.
But for the record the North Koreans
still claim villages are in there.
So I label -- so you can see
the shape of Phyonggang County
around here and I was
able to map this
out on the satellite imagery
using this map published
in North Korea in 1997.
I have maps like this
for every country,
it's just the North Korean atlas
that's published by [inaudible]
in 1997 and this is it here.
And then they label the re
on there and you can look
at the satellite imagery and confirm
that there's actually a
village where they say it is.
And then in 2012 I got this, a
North Korean encyclopedia set,
it's a digital encyclopedia
it's not a book
that the North Korean published.
And it has a [inaudible].
And this is Phyonggang
County from that map.
I don't know when it was published,
I think sometime in
the early 2000's.
But anyway, for Phyonggang
County it was different right,
it had added on this section
that took all the re villages
[inaudible] the county border,
it moved over and then up
here had been brought down.
So then I had to go and
redraw all of my study.
I assumed that this was the most
accurate since it was the newest
and it was published in North
Korea, but I couldn't find anything
that the North Koreans had published
in KCNA or read on something
where they said that they
changed these borders
around all I have is this.
But I thought well
it's the newest one,
so I'll accept this
as the most accurate.
And then the North Koreans launched
a large agricultural project here,
it's called the [inaudible]
Table Land Project,
the Mongolians are helping they
gave like 10,000 heads of cattle
for the North Koreans to revive
their livestock numbers here.
And so the North Koreans
have been talking
about all the livestock farms
they're building in this region
and then they showed
all of the counties
that they're building
in on television.
And they used the old county shape.
So I was like oh, I just changed it.
So I went back and
switched it to the old one,
this old one in here
actually matches the one
that was on television.
And this is actually a giant map
right that was physically made
and [inaudible] has
been there to deal
with the [inaudible]
Table Land construction.
So I accept this as
-- it has the virtue
of being the most published
map of the county,
but accepted as more
accurate as well.
Even though I have a North Korean
source that conflicts with it.
And here's another kind of
problem that I've had to face
on the administrative side.
This is a Hyesan City, oh yeah
this is North Koreans spell the
[inaudible] Province the South
Koreans don't spell it that way.
But this is Hyesan City, this is a
1997 map that I used to map it out.
So this circle right
here this is a re village
and the South Koreans don't call
them res they call them [inaudible].
But anyway, they forgot to put
the name of this village here.
I found it in a source
and it was [inaudible].
Here's [inaudible] and oops and
this is a 2005 satellite image
of these villages.
I'm going to verify
they were all there.
They were in the process of being
torn down actually, of being erased
from the map because they
were building a dam there.
And so this is what it looks like 12
of these villages have
all been flooded out.
And you can see on
the satellite imagery
where the villages have been moved
to other, they've rebuilt them
in surrounding areas, but I
didn't know which one was which.
And you guys can't understand
how frustrating that is.
But eventually North Korea
under [inaudible] has
announced yearly a little
over 20 specialty county zones,
see these [inaudible] in Hyesan.
And they gave on television they
show this map they gave the location
of the [inaudible] one of these
Peninsulas on this reservoir.
But they showed the names of
where they moved the villages.
And so they haven't published
any maps certainly that I'm aware
of that have this updated
information, I was only able
to find it just by watching North
Korean television every day.
You guys should pay me for that.
So anyway, now I have an
updated map of Hyesan City
and it has the reservoir here and it
has the villages in the proper place
around the outskirts of it.
And so that's it, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ryan Moore: So this
is time for questions.
If you have a question if you could
just raise your hand and stand up
and speak loudly so everyone
can hear your question.
If you're in a back and you can't
hear the question I'll be happy
to repeat it and allow Mr.
Melvin to jump in and answer.
The front here please.
>> In conjunction with the
Voice of America Mr. Melvin,
you said your end goal is
to participate [inaudible].
When do you expect
that could be launched?
>> Curtis Melvin: I'm not going
to give you a date on that
because I've already
been wrong so many times.
I'm going home today to
work on it, but I don't know
when it will be finished.
Hopefully in the next year.
Do you want to call,
it doesn't matter.
>> You talk about the
defectors [inaudible].
But my question is [inaudible]
defectors how far do they actually
move into different territories
to be able to [inaudible]?
>> Curtis Melvin: Yeah, almost --
I've met a handful of defectors
from Pyongyang not many,
less than 10 actually,
maybe about 10.
But most North Koreans
know where they were from
and the route they took
to get out and that's it.
And where they're from they
really don't know much farther
than literally like
their village so.
And I ask questions like where
is the central bank branch,
I don't know.
Where's the people's
committee, I don't know.
You know, so it's a lot of
work to get a small amount
of information out of them.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, so I've been doing this
for too long since say 2006,
I've been actively working on this,
so it's coming up on 10 years.
I've been fortunate enough to meet
a lot of people who have been in
and out of North Korea or
have the opportunity to go
in and out a lot of times.
And so if there's a book out that
I want I can ask someone to get it
or someone might be thoughtful
enough to get it for me.
But in terms of permanent
staff who want
to help me US Korean Institute gives
me interns to work on this project,
they help with a lot
of translation work.
There's a learning curve on it
because they're usually South Korean
and they don't -- they've never
homes seen any North Korean sources
and the language is
sometimes a barrier
and they use North Korean words
and they don't know anything
about North Korean geography.
But it takes time to develop trust
in people like I have information
that I know about, but I
want to get another source
for it before I add it to the
collection of data and that's just
to be a good person in my opinion.
I don't want to name
names or anything so.
Yup.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
No, no intelligence agency has ever
asked for my mapping information.
The use is mostly for academic
and media use and policymakers.
There's a tremendous amount of
ignorance of North Korean geography,
I mean I don't mean that
like people are ignorant
because they don't [inaudible],
there's not really a big
reason for most people to know.
But as North Korea is certainly a
country that's in the news a lot
and a country of concern.
I prefer to give good
information on North Korea
and I think this is a valuable
platform for doing that.
>> What was your observation
of the economic developments
of North Korea based
on what you're seeing,
is it [inaudible] progressing
on economic development here
in manufacturing or
agriculture or both?
>> Curtis Melvin: Yeah, you
know, it's a big mystery.
I mean, you know, North
Korea has never --
they stopped publishing net material
product tables in the 1960's.
Net material product
tables were what we used
from other communist countries to
estimate the size of their GDP.
There is an entire
literature on this
and I'll spare you the
complications, but it's a lot of art
and science, it's a rigorous
attempt but it's not perfect
to establish a value for
official output in North Korea.
But now there's a black market in
North Korea and there's not even --
the government hasn't published a
budget since 2001 and, you know,
they only publish percent
increases and decreases in spending
on selected items each year.
It's mostly an advertising
or signaling device,
it's not anything you can use
to rigorously estimate
the official budget.
So really the big good news I guess
economically from North Korea is
that they've stopped
the inflation that began
after the 2009 currency revaluation.
We don't really know how
they've stopped this inflation,
but the black market exchange
rate has been relatively stable
for the one since 2012.
The number of markets that exist
in the country have increased
a little bit under Kim Jong-Il,
but he's shown no propensity
like his father to clampdown
on market activity or
to restrict free prices
of commodities in those markets.
And he still hasn't visited one,
we still haven't seen any official
North Korean person involved
in economic matters visit
an official marketplace.
But we can see on satellite imagery
that they're continuing to grow
and expand, so that's
a positive development.
The South Korean Bank of Korea
publishes an annual estimate
of the North Korean economy and
they've shown basically a plus
or minus 1% each year since
Kim Jong-Il took office.
A lot of people, myself included,
think that the actual growth rate,
at least in Pyongyang has
been substantially higher
than that just based on qualitative
assessments on the amounts
of consumer goods that are available
to North Koreans today
compared to say 10 years ago.
You cannot defend that position
with any standard econometric tools
because the data is not
available to do that.
We're really trying to
triangulate official economic news,
satellite information,
information from defectors,
information that creeps
across the border
to put together a coherent
picture of what's happening
in specific industries and
that's really the best we can do.
>> Ryan Moore: We have time
for one more [inaudible].
>> Yes, is the digital
atlas available online?
>> Curtis Melvin: Yeah,
the administrative information
is already available.
It's for 2012, so it's probably --
the most recent version is probably
like maybe 7 or 8% different,
but it's largely available
at 38North.org.
No, no it's just a web platform.
Yeah you can.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, in English and Korean you can
search it in English and Korean.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I had no idea, you know, excuse
me most of the, you know,
for the [inaudible] I'm
really not a computer guy.
But the RGIS database
that is Gazetteer data
and I don't like it so.
All right, thank you.
>> Ryan Moore: Thank
you everyone for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.